Chris asks, he says, is the one-pager borrow idea still an option or has Google started
preventing that by giving you a message of plagiarized content when you go to run ads?
So far for me, that's never happened.
Now I do know that Daniela had an issue with one of her ads that she put up as a one-pager,
but I know she was using a .godaddy or something like that.
I don't know if it had to do with it being a .godaddy.
I've never had any issues, so I'm still going to roll with that until I have an issue.
I'm going to keep rolling with that.
So as far as I know, and just so everybody knows, I still use a whatever it is,
cityservice.weebly.com with borrowed content, right?
Because I'm never going to index the site.